see how many of these i can fit in my
mouth
you have to unshell them all
hey buzzfeed i'm whitney and i'm mallory
and we start in the movie stop and go
[Applause]
and today we are ranking the top road
trip snacks
oh i'm gonna get to you
seeds you'll be mine
you want some
yeah
i rank these very low because i have no
idea how to eat them they put all the
flavoring on the outside on the shell
it's how people do it and then you have
this little shell
i won't lie it's good
it's good but it's not enough meat for
me i give it a one yeah because i was
gonna give it a two it makes me feel bad
about myself any snack you have to have
a spit bucket for are we
in the 1800s
okay
parmesan cheese crisps i mean oven baked
13 grams of protein per serving they
ain't messing around
10 out of 5. delicious i used to take
powdered parmesan as a kid i just pour
it into my hand oh yeah eat it lick it
off yeah
it was like frosting
[Music]
we were talking about this yeah this is
the one we were both
i love beef jerky
that's a strong one too oh that's good
okay i just love it
this is my probably my top here's my top
for sure this and chocolate i could go
across the country same i just i need
both oh this is a huge case i'm gonna
eat it
yeah
how are you going to tear it
whoa
i would rank this
solid vibe
didn't even have to work for it
it was just born with talent
[Music]
these are trollies which i think are the
superior brand of most gummy worms is
there even another brand aren't there
other brands just horrible
worms they're good with bears yeah
holiday does the bears oh
i'm gonna eat that part
i'm gonna say for this
i would give it a four
because i love them
well i love them so much but
they will they will make me so sick and
become if i eat the whole bag
and i will eat the whole bag the rule
with snacks is that one serving is the
entire container no matter how big the
cake what are you trying to fool fda
[Music]
we have a cliff bar energy bar energy
bar protein bar
i mean
i call this the snack i eat before my
real meal
i fully a couple of weeks ago had had a
full like just like a regular sized sick
snickers for the first time since i was
like a kid it is essentially the same
and it tastes so much better than a clif
bar so
my gosh you're right zero
i mean i was going to give it like a two
because i will always eat one because
it's fine yeah
[Music]
can i tell you this is bringing me so
much joy right now because i actually
haven't been able to have dairy since
2017
and um
nutella has cream in it so you can have
it i mean i can like
i could lick this little tip
i'm gonna give it two ratings
i'm gonna give it a 500 if i'm sitting
in the car yes but i am going to give it
a three if i'm driving yeah you know
it's just like very i want it so bad i
need i need somebody to pre-dip all of
them for me
[Laughter]
there it is i want it so badly a little
girl this is the new diet trend
i think you just dab it on the edge of
your nose you'll smell it all day and
it's just like you got to eat it but no
calorie
[Laughter]
well we did it
thank you buzzfeed this has been
delicious
and i've learned so much make sure to go
and see stop and go and i will be
just shotguning me
oh
how was that
got a whole serving and one mouthful
i make her smell like beef jerky and
tara gummy we love food we do